[Music]
let's chat about the ultimatum who the
ultimatum it's a new netflix show
anything's scarier than losing you right
now would be to marry you
you're here because someone in your
relationship has issued an ultimatum i'm
not ready to propose take a good look
around at each other you're gonna find
out if there are people here who might
be a better fit at the end of the week
you'll each choose a new partner you'll
move in together for three weeks at the
end of this experience you guys will
have to choose to marry person you've
arrived here with or to split forever
any relationship is gonna survive this
[ __ ] uh yeah i mean i would hope that's
what i love about temptation island when
there's always that couple where the one
dude it's like the woman is in the
nicest way possible trying to call him
like a [ __ ] a wimp and he'll just be
in the house and everyone's like
mingling and stuff he's like nah i'm
gonna keep it loyal it's like dude
she came on this show for a reason
yeah yeah and you're standing there
she's like nah she's probably being
loyal over there
she hates you man no i know there's also
gonna be a guy who's like [ __ ]
crazy like narc he's just like yeah my
girlfriend is just she's so like
just like not a good time then like it's
always like the most sheepish like
polite girl is like i don't know like i
i think i get on his nerves so like i'm
just trying not to upset him today he's
the first one to be like you want to
[ __ ] right now yeah unfortunately i
think we're all right yep i am hooked
that is an incredible concept i thought
it was when i saw the the title and the
billboard for it i thought they were
gonna like say how could we take love is
blind and make it even crazier it's just
two people they walk in opposite sides
two doors open
kind of girl walk in they look at each
other and the guy has to propose i just
imagined like a sharp cut right there to
the next netflix trailer of nick and his
wife being like we're gonna speed things
up welcome to the question and that's
what it is if the guy wants to even
engage with the girl like if he's like i
like the way she looks right now i would
like to say hi or just to get to know
her a little bit better they have to
marry just what a formula um
one little show hit one time they're
like all right we gotta try everything
in this genre let's milk this for
everything that it is it's so cheap they
buy one set of cameras camera operators
that work in reality they don't get a
day rate it's not like a dp it's like
it's hourly
so that [ __ ] is cheap they pay them like
dirt right so yeah 18 bucks an hour hold
this [ __ ] camera yeah filming for 10
hours a day that's like not [ __ ] to them
yeah who do they have writing the
concepts of these shows you think they
just like go in a room and just like
brainstorm the craziest [ __ ] like i bet
you someone has actually come up with
that idea that i just did yeah in the
room yeah most writers i think are
pretty crazy yeah like ooh like what if
we
that's all it is i bet you they have a
backlog of [ __ ]
horrible yes that's what i'm saying we
have this one idea for a show where
basically um
you know a bunch of couples go up to
some skydiving yeah but it's a little
bit of a twist to do it in a military
plane why are they doing it in a
military plane because right before they
jump they're given the option do you
want to stay with your partner or go on
a new adventure and they both find out
who wants to stay and who wants to go on
a new adventure
on the jump those who jump want to go on
a new adventure those who stay want to
stay in the couple and it's just a hyper
cut of [ __ ]
just shitty dudes being like
i thought you were gonna say [ __ ] up
like because like these shows are really
[ __ ] they toy with these people's
emotions
oh no here yeah here would be a [ __ ]
up one it's like temptation island on
steroids they
separate like some couples in like
houses and they can only communicate via
like written messages and bottles okay
and the producers are just making up
whatever the other person's saying
or just you know oh yeah yeah okay or
just like psychological terror like that
that [ __ ] that they do on temptation
island is so crazy when they just show
them those out of context clips what do
they do oh man well the last season was
[ __ ] there was no way to kind of
manipulate that so is it like uh casso
moore yeah okay where they just like
show clips to them like making out with
other people yeah and it's like their
girlfriend boyfriend right yeah okay
yeah there was one guy who like he's
like that stereotype i'm talking about
like the dude who's like has like the
utmost confidence just bagging on his
girl like he went straight to like
fooling around and [ __ ] and then when he
saw clips of his girl like getting on
with another dude oh my god this guy's
just like
god that's [ __ ] up yeah the
cameraman's like let's go
i mean that dude was a [ __ ] i wasn't
doing it yeah exactly yeah
yeah loved it yeah
i wanted more what about they didn't
what what if they did like a netflix
show where like they had you know
different like little
structures and you had to guess whether
or not they were cake
what do you think of that idea
i'm not seeing the show you're
referencing
you haven't seen that no it's called is
this cake it's on netflix it's a real
[ __ ] show play the
play no no we can't do this is this k is
it a game show like can you win money
this is a bowling ball
and this is a cake
you want to show his name you are all
here because you are all talented at
making cakes that look like everyday
objects
cake and now and also an incredibly
specific skill and also here's a clip of
your boyfriend cheating on you in the
green room
what what a combination is like a
[ __ ]
frankenstein of all the worst netflix
shows dude is this cake and he hacks it
open it's a small screen in there
showing the clip of the boyfriend
cheating so is it cake is it cake or not
yes i guess
[Applause]
[Music]
they cut into the clip
like the screen it's actually just a
holographic cake there was no clip there
it wasn't real your boyfriend is
actually cheating on you though
he is cheating on you and then like cuts
to him in an apartment and he's playing
the circle
god [ __ ] hollywood is getting crazy
there's another show right now a food
show
called uh i forget but it's like one
phony
like six real chefs and one phony and
they like
bake something and the phony has to like
prove that they're i don't know like not
not get caught basically the speed at
which like everyone just copies each
other and makes the same [ __ ] yeah i
mean it's it's all it's like youtube man
it's just all
content wars yeah everyone just vying to
be the first one to something yeah
content wars dude what if we oh a squid
games sketch yeah
no we should do content wars where we
take
12 youtubers and um we give them all
weapons
yeah and it's just a fight to the death
and the one who remains gets a
sponsorship from red camera okay
okay yeah yeah i could see some legal
issues with that they've shot with
cameras can they shoot
with gyros
no no it's gotta be more gruesome okay
bow and arrow yeah oh my god i can't
believe i just put a [ __ ] arrow into
scottie syre's head
just take youtubers from different
generations yeah no but mr beast has to
host it yeah whoa like all him and his
all of his friends standing there hey
whoa whoa whoa that air on his head oh
look at cupid over here all right we're
moving on well face rug is dead
all right we're moving on just like some
makeup artist there's some beauty
youtuber just bow and arrow
i just killed faze rug yeah he just
um this guy is dying of blood loss
let's move on
geez we haven't seen someone lose this
hard since the squid game sketch hey
phase rug 50k right now if you stay
alive
you